the action that is taking place
in the east of the country i mean boris
johnson himself
has already expressed concern for the
donbass region i mean is there now an
inevitability
to the russians taking territory in that
part of the country
i don't think there's an inevitability
at all i mean i think the last time that
i had the privilege of uh speaking for
the government in the morning was about
two or three weeks ago and we were
reflecting then on how uh imminent the
demise of mario paul may be and yet
those fighters that are in mario paul
defending it so heroically are still
going through slater and they are
soaking up a huge amount of russian
combat power as that defense continues
so um i think that what we will see in
the donbass is a very different type of
conflict to the one that we saw uh
around kiev i think we'll see a conflict
between two forces that are much more
evenly balanced uh where the ukrainians
have the advantage of defensive
positions that have been
dug in and prepared over the last eight
years and that's going to make it an
extraordinarily difficult nut for the
russians to crack
and i think that with all of the support
that the ukrainians are getting from
around the world there's every chance
that the ukrainians can see them off
we know that the ukrainians certainly
have been fighting and fighting hard
your boss ben wallace was briefing mps
yesterday and viewers can see it on the
screen perhaps as many as 15 000 russian
personnel have been killed perhaps as
many as 30 of the battalion tactical
groups
yeah i mean that's right those are the
numbers that the ukrainians report and
that is and that's vast that is nearly
three times as many uh
dead as russia suffered in the first
chechen war
and
and that is
that is
nobody should rejoice in that that's 15
000 russian families who haven't got
their son or husband or brother coming
home
but
people in russia should be clear that
that is because
the russian plan has been
defined by incredible hubris massive
political interference in military plan
making and we're seeing exactly the same
now
where there is pressure from moscow to
deliver a victory by the 9th of may so
that putin can have a nice parade
through red square
even though that makes no military sense
the weather in the donbass over the last
week or so has been absolutely awful and
so driving the russian army to launch an
offensive now simply so putin can have a
nice day in the sun on may the 9th is
just going to cost russia thousands more
lives now if you're on the side of the
ukrainians and you want the ukrainians
to succeed in defending their territory
that russian hubris is a massive massive
advantage for ukraine but if i was a
russian family i'd be deeply concerned
that those in the kremlin were not
acting in my interests indeed
on that point then minister what what
more can you tell us about the
additional assistance that we're
providing a lot of kind of speculation
perhaps informed speculation in the
papers about storm or vehicles being
sent perhaps as uh providing some form
of radar as well what more can you tell
us on that
well that's exactly right and you know
the secretary of state has been very
very clear that russia only has itself
to blame because every time we have gone
up a gear in terms of what we are
providing it is a direct consequence of
the way that russia has conducted its
operations
in ukraine
now stormer is a air defense facility
that is mounted on an armored vehicle we
think that that's necessary uh in order
to
give greater protection to ukrainian
ground forces and the civilian
populations in some cities
we have been scouring the earth for
uh 152 millimeter artillery ammunition
which is uh the artillery ammunition
that the ukrainians would need for their
existing guns um but we've also now been
working with allies around the world to
provide them with uh 155 millimeter
which is the nato standard caliber
and that means that hundreds of
thousands more artillery rounds are now
flowing in from the united states
particularly to ukraine there are
countries in eastern europe that are
giving up sophisticated air defense
systems hundreds of tanks um i mean this
is an amazing effort and the uk has been
to the fore in corralling it
the the response though from the
russians in particular then the foreign
minister sergey lavrov
warning that
this could be as on the precipice of
world war three already suggesting that
russia is not fighting ukraine it's it's
fighting nato i mean obviously that
clearly removes you know the ukrainians
agency and all of this but i wonder what
you make of the at the brinksmanship in
terms of the rhetoric about potentially
your third global conflict
well look i mean there's a couple of
points of distinction firstly the donor
community is not nato nato uh has been
involved in uh reinforcing its eastern
flank so a lot of the deployments of our
troops ships and aircraft to eastern
europe are very much under the nato flag
but the donor effort is something that
is being brought together by countries
that are from yes many of them are from
nato but others are from beyond the
australians the kiwis the canadians uh
sorry the canadians are in nato um and
and so you know that is uh it's not nato
that is doing the the the military aid
but sergey lavrov might also reflect
that the reason that there is a war in
ukraine right now is because russia
rolled over the borders of a sovereign
country and started to invade their
territory nato is not an expansionist
offensive alliance nato is a defensive
alliance and
all of this noise from moscow about
somehow
uh their their attack on ukraine being a
response to nato aggression it's just
utter utter nonsense
um minister i wonder if we can move away
from from from your brief now to perhaps
the kind of the biggest individual issue
facing your politics and indeed the
public domestically the the cost of
living we understand that there is to be
a cost of living cabinet today the prime
minister very keen to get as many ideas
as possible you know for as little money
as possible given what we've been
spending over the past few years
what is the hope from this meeting this
morning
well look i mean the reason that the
meeting is happening and the reason that
so many meetings on the cost of living
happen in government every single day
is because the moment that you go out
and knock on doors in your constituency
what you find
is that that is the thing that
hard-working families across the united
kingdom are most concerned about the
cost of living is getting to such a
point now where even people on good
wages are struggling to make ends meet
and they are looking to the government
to help them with solutions now what
they were deciding cabinet this morning
is for them and it's certainly not for
me to to try and trail but already for
this year alone the government's put 22
billion pounds of targeted funding in to
support those who are struggling most
with the cost of living and the fact
that cabinet is meeting today to discuss
it more shows you just how seriously
this is taken by the prime minister the
chancellor and the rest of their
colleagues and cabinets but it isn't the
simple truth though i mean i've read the
article that the the sun was briefed on
on the cabinet meeting taking place this
morning and the kind of the one of the
biggest announcement one of the biggest
policies that was was flagged up in the
article was removing tariffs on rice now
i understand that that will help you
know but we're talking pennies and not
pounds i mean isn't the simple truth
that there's not an awful lot that the
government can do without spending money
well i mean
there's no doubt about it that these
interventions are expensive 22 billion
pounds of government intervention to
assist in uh to assist with families
with their cost of living is already
huge there'll be other levers that
government can pull and you know
not no one of them will be a golden
bullet but cumulatively if you can
provide people with lots of small
savings across their cost of living then
cumulatively that does start to make a
difference so i wouldn't
i wouldn't sniff at the removal of a
tariff on a particular food type because
if that sits alongside
a resistance a reduction in
fuel duty at the pumps which has
happened if that sits alongside a rising
of the personal allowance an increase in
the national living wage you know
cumulatively you can start to see and
you know and assisting people with their
energy bills cumulative you can start to
see how that starts to ease the pressure
on the families who are struggling the
most minister i i promise you i am not
being sniffy about cheaper rice you have
no idea how much curry i eat um i do
however want us to conclude on just
on a couple of related topics around
around freedom of speech um angela
raynor of course you will by now have
seen that the article such as it was in
the mail on sunday i i have to admit i
feel slightly uncomfortable this morning
yesterday clearly we were talking with
your colleague chris phil the article
itself misogynistic sexist and all the
rest of it and then we hear that the
speaker of the house of commons has
summoned the mail on sunday's editor for
a meeting presumably to chastise him
does that sit easily with you you know
the speaker of the house of commons
summoning a journalist to explain their
actions
well look
lindsay is fiercely independent and
rightly so uh you know he is the speaker
of the house of commons and he must do
what he thinks is in parliament's
interest i would just reflect that you
know i don't think that the speaker is
trying to limit freedom of speech in
fact my understanding was i wasn't in
the chamber yesterday to hear him say it
firsthand my understanding is that he
made the point of saying that he wants
to protect freedom of speech and that
the role of the press
lobby in parliament is hugely important
um but there are female colleagues
in the house of commons on all sides of
the house
who have to put up with a level of
sexism misogyny every day that frankly
is unfair uh it is a disadvantage to
them that
i don't have to face as a male member of
parliament or a male minister and i just
can't believe that in 2022 we're in a
place where
the story that was written on sunday was
was written i can't believe that one of
my colleagues the story was written
because your colleagues i think it's
despicable
and i i i just find it outrageous that
that colleague who who sits within a
party that has delivered two female
prime ministers that has two women in
the great offices of state that is
surrounded by amazingly capable female
mps on the conservative benches as well
as over on the labour benches too i just
i just don't know what parliament that
they think they sit in i just i find the
whole thing ridiculous offensive i'm
sorry for angela um and i you know if
the speaker is going to put a shot
across the bowels about the way that
women in parliament are being reported
that's a good thing i have no doubt that
he is
protecting freedom of speech and he
won't want to see that impringed but i
do think that westminster has just got
itself into a mess and it it looks awful
yeah
to continue with the freedom of speech
um theme what what are your thoughts
about the the taking private of uh
social media platform uh twitter by elon
musk i mean the bills certainly aren't
there and the board obviously still has
to agree but do you have any concerns
about the richest man in the world
owning perhaps one of the most
significant social media platforms
well i i the government doesn't have a
view the government will let this go
through as as a as a transaction um but
there is
um i think you know elon musk has made
some good noises about being a protector
of freedom of speech i think i've also
heard him say some stuff about uh ending
the anonymity of the trolls on on
twitter
and you know those of us who use twitter
as part of our jobs
will know that twitter can be an
absolute sewer sometimes because people
do have anonymity and that makes them
very brave uh when they have anonymity
um i if twitter is going to be cleaned
up as a platform uh be
somewhere where freedom of speech is
championed um but the anonymous
anonymous abuse becomes uh more
difficult then that's a good thing but
that's my view and the government's view
is that this is a this is a takeover bit
on which we have no view at the moment
jcp great to have you on the program as
always thanks for joining us thanks now
thank you